dieser schwedische film ist dermaßen gut
letzte mal dass ich was gesehen habe was
mich so überzeugt hat war vor 30 jahren
als ridley scott versucht hat kunst und
science fiction zusammenzubringen aber
so lasst uns mal im jahr ist die
verfilmung eines gedichtes nicht gerne
nicht abschalten zu hören
das gedicht ist 956 beschrieben worden
von harry martin sondern der dafür 1974
auch noch den nobelpreis gekriegt hat
diesen schönen literatur nobelpreis den
heute nur noch harvey stammtisch und
diese leute bekommen das allererste
daran ist dass das gericht wirklich
verfilmt wurde nicht einfach nur
zusammen geschnetzelt oder irgendwie
umgebaut bis es ein film wird das heißt
es ist ein epos also ein gedicht über
viele viele gesänge das heißt hat ne
story sowie die szene story hat und die
story wird tatsächlich relativ facebook
relativ treu abgebildet aber so dass
sachen die bei martin von drei zeilen
sind und dann vorstellungen becken zu
ende formuliert sind wobei ein gedicht
formulierten film zeigt das heißt du
hast wirklich den eindruck wie bei guten
roman oder comicverfilmung ja genau so
ist das hab ich mir das dann lesen
gedacht ich wusste nicht wie es ganz
genau aussieht jetzt weiß ich ist ich
habe den film das erste mal mit jemandem
gesehen die das gedicht nicht kannte und
konnte immer so geräusche von mir geben
das will man ja gerne wie auf war ja
wenn ich wusste jetzt kommt der schlimme
teil und es war dann so es war also
einerseits an diesem bild faden entlang
gefilmt und andererseits von einer kraft
das irgendwie denkst wenn du in zwei
versionen so eine geschichte sie ist als
literatur und als film und bei beiden
denkst es ist die richtige art zu
erzählen dann kriegt es eine ganz andere
wirklichkeit auf einmal auch dann denkst
du na ja das ist halt wie die ewig immer
wieder erzählten geschichten wie robin
hood oder irgendwas wo du sagst das ist
irgendwie mythen bestand und du kannst
es auf 1000 verschiedene arten erzählen
wir haben ein
keine wahl und mussten unsere treibstoff
vollständig ab das bedeutet dass wir die
an jahren und leider nicht mehr steuern
können wir sind von unserem kurs
abgekommen und können nicht zurückkehren
das war ein gedicht das davon handelte
wie wir die welt versauen und wie das
vor allen dingen gesellschaftliches
problem ist weil wir nämlich auch
scheiße zueinander sind das heißt
eigentlich all das was die klima
menschen alle durchs mikro mikrofonen
durchs megaphon schreien aber in diesem
gedicht wird es auf eine art formuliert
die nicht einfach nur flugblatt ist
sondern die tief in das geht was mit uns
eigentlich los ist seit wir wissenschaft
technik und diesen ganzen modernen
schönen gründer haben den wir brauchen
bekommen
toyota
das ding ist tatsächlich weltweit
ziemlich eingeschlagen es gibt eine
tolle französische übersetzung es gibt
eine chinesische übersetzung die wird
viel gelesen wird
es gibt eigentlich in allen sprachen
version es gibt eine deutsche- die man
nur noch zu science fiction preisen bei
amazon kaufen kann weil die damals
gemacht wurde zur premiere der oper es
gibt nämlich auch noch eine oper also
dieser stoff ist tatsächlich ein so
multimedialer deswegen wahrscheinlich
demnächst auch noch als pantomime und
als rock video und wahrscheinlich
irgendwie als brettspiel und
computersimulation kriegen
[Musik]
das hamburger weg sozialismus
das besondere an diesem film ist dass er
es schafft all die sachen die man
eigentlich nicht wissen konnte rhein zu
nehmen und zu wissen und zu zeigen dass
heißt wenn er zum beispiel sich eine
gesellschaft vorstellt die irgendwann
dermaßen die verantwortung abgibt
an allem was um sie herum passiert das
nur noch getanzt wird und gefühl willst
dann hat er sich das so vorgestellt wie
man sich das 56 vorstellen nämlich mit
swing party und pipapo
und in diesem film ist es aber eine
clubatmosphäre in diesem film ist das
raumschiff mit dem die menschen zum mars
fliegen wollen was dann schiefgeht so
dass sie auch eine irrfahrt geschickt
werden durch einen unfall von innen so
was wie eine mall oder in spa oder ein
wellness center das ist alles vollkommen
richtig das ist alles genau das grauen
das uns gerade erwartet dass wir uns
gerade schon aus kochen
dass alle tollste daran für jemand der
diese hollywood gesichter irgendwann
nicht mehr sehen kann weil er denkt okay
jetzt verwandelt sich das den hofft man
wieder in irgendetwas weil er sonst
nichts anderes kann aus als ich ihnen
alles möglich verwandeln ist dass die
leute zum ersten mal sie ist also emily
haber die hauptfigur mima roben hat eine
wahnsinnig magnetische wirkung und noch
besser als sie ist eine figur die es so
wie in dem film in dem buch gar nicht
gibt aber eigentlich geben sollte weil
der martinsson führen dichter und
unglaubliches gespür dafür hat wie
poetisch aufgeladen eigentlich
technisches fachwissen expertise
wissenschaft sind und deswegen hat er
dauernd diese astronomen und piloten und
diese leute die er bewundert aber dem
auch ein bisschen unheimlich sind und
eine davon ist dann tatsächlich die
faszinierendste figur in diesem film die
schauspieler heißt alle martini das
urgestein des theaters seien in schweden
oder so und das ist eine raum bautzen
will
wenn walter matthau eine frau wäre oder
gene hackman oder so was die ist einfach
die liegt am anfang in der kabine dies
die einzigen den ganzen dreck
durchschaut also wenn dann die trost
sprüche immer kommen vom captain
irgendwie wir haben das alles im griff
und wir kommen wieder auf kurs und so
zieht sie einfach nur sein gesicht was
als gesicht vollkommen recht als kritik
an all dem schund der einen ganzen tag
erzählt wird von wegen regt euch nicht
auf wird schon alles wieder gut
und das ist das ist eine so tolle
gestalt tatsächlich das ist so ich
könnte mir vorstellen dass wenn junge
leute den film gucken dass das so bei
ihnen bleibt wie dr mccoy und spock bei
uns geblieben sind als wir irgendwie die
alten star trek dinge gesehen haben und
allein für diese frau lohnt sich das
dermaßen sind filme anzugucken also ich
hoffe es gibt irgendwann eine längere
version auf blu ray oder so mit 700
geschnittenen szenen mit ihr wo sie
einfach nur alles verachtet was um sie
herum passiert und so dermaßen recht hat
und dabei aber nicht kalt und zynisch
ist sondern die ist das hirn und das
herz
dann